Hello world. It's a Raj
and cryptocurrencies are
fast going mainstream.
I'll show you how to use python to perform
sentiment analysis on reddit and put
her data and predict whether the price
of bitcoin will go up or down on a given
day. When people share data online,
there's usually some attitude or opinion,
some kind of emotion that's expressed
with their share. If we read their data,
be it a tweet or a comment,
we can pretty much glean what that
emotion is by looking at their context and
wording.
Sentiment analysis is the process of
automating this kind of analysis using
artificial intelligence,
which allows us to scale it massively.
The applications of this
process are pretty broad.
Many organizations across the world are
using this ability to extract insights
from social data to
better target customers,
predict market trends and exploit
emotionally vulnerable youth.
Some day we will dethrone news Zuckerberg,
the Obama administration,
for example,
used sentiment analysis to gauge public
policy opinion during announcements
ahead of the 2012 presidential election.
The travel company.
Expedia use it to realize that their
customers didn't like the music behind
their ad campaign,
which resulted in a new virgin
that was received very well.
Investment firms use it to understand
how shareholders are feeling about a
certain company's stock when deciding
whether to buy or sell and this lets them
stay a step ahead of the competition.
Ever since Bitcoin's
price began to skyrocket,
there has been this constant hype
surrounding the cryptocurrency market.
All coins are popping up every day.
Some are scams,
some make it to the top of
the coin list in months.
The topic is coming up
everywhere. Radio, Twitter,
the awkward bathroom stall conversations,
but what is causing these
digital currencies to
fluctuate in price? Right now?
The answer is mostly speculation.
Crypto prices right now are
being driven by network usage.
They're being driven by speculation
that the tokens are going to appreciate.
It's a gold rush mentality.
If people expect the price
of a cryptocurrency to
increase due to a utility
increase over time,
like more merchants accepting it,
a growth in transaction volume or a
larger ecosystem of developers building on
top of it,
there will be a rise in demand,
assuming that the supply does not
increase in the same proportion,
the price will go up.
But if the utility decreases because of
reasons like mobile platforms blocking
it,
technical issues,
governments banning it or exchange
markets getting shut down,
the demand will decrease,
but the supply will increase since
more people are willing to sell.
So the price will go
down in the long term.
The value of digital currencies will be
way more determined by their utility and
less so by speculation.
But we can take advantage of this
speculation driven market by analyzing the
sentiment of the speculators on
social media using machine learning.
So for this demo,
we're going to aggregate data from people
about bitcoin from reddit and Twitter.
We'll also collect bitcoin price data
from coindesk.com then we'll use a
recurrent neural network that try and
find a correlation between social media
sentiment and the bitcoin price.
Once trained,
we can use our model to make
predictions about the future price.
The bitcoin subreddit is one of the
biggest big coin communities in the world.
Everyday people share news articles,
tutorials,
and events related to bitcoin and the
top posts get up voted accordingly.
Yes,
it's a bunch of handlers.
We can use a red at API to pull the top
posts from this subreddit for the past
30 days. We can combine this
data with data from Twitter,
specifically tweets that used the
word bitcoin using the Twitter Api.
It's essentially going to be a lot
of text data, so to clean this up,
we'll use a prebuilt dictionary with
a top 10 k most common words to remove
words that are not in the dictionary will
also use the coindesk API to pull the
bitcoin price from the past 30 days and
generate two classes using this data
because zero means a price went up.
One means the price went down.
Now that we've compiled the Dataset,
we can build an appropriate
model for this data.
One thing we could do
is build a bag of words.
This means attempting to separate each
word in a data point into a list of words,
Aka a bag so that each word carries
meaning with respect to the overall reddit
or Twitter posts.
And we could use a simple deep neural
network to predict the price of bitcoin
goes up or down based on this.
But the problem with this model is that
it doesn't preserve the ordering between
words,
meaning the network won't recognize
complex ideas that span many words.
We need a model that will let us input
words in order that will understand that
our data is sequential.
That's why we'll use a recurrent
network at every time step.
We're inputting not just
the next data point,
but the hidden state from
the previous time step.
And when it comes to price prediction,
long short term memory,
recurrent networks or lsms have been shown
to give the best results because they
remember longterm sequences,
which is what we have LSTM networks.
He's a special cell structure
involving three gates,
which stores the gradient during the
optimization process in a way that allows
it to fully update all the layers of
the network instead of diminishing over
time. A common problem when
training recurrent networks,
these dates are essentially a form of
memory and their weights are updated as
well.
During the optimization process,
gates are way to optionally
let information through.
They are composed of a sigmoid neural
net layer and a point wise multiplication
operation.
The sigmoid layer outputs numbers between
zero and one describing how much of
each component should be let through a
value of zero means let nothing through.
While a value of one means
let everything through.
So an Lstm has three of these gates
to protect and control the cell state.
They're like plumbing valves without the,
you know. Yeah. You know what I mean?
So we can vectorize each of our
social media posts using word two VEC.
This is a pre trained a neural network
that we can use to immediately turn our
words into vectors.
These vectors are representations of
words and allow us to measure how similar
words are. Mathematically. It's a better,
more machine readable representation of
text that we can correlate with bitcoin
prices.
Once vectorized we'll feed our input
data to our model with the associated
binary labels in batches.
Care Os allows us to build complex
deep networks quite easily,
so we'll use it with a tensorflow
backend for our training process.
We'll let our network make predictions
about the price for each input data point.
Then compare that prediction
with the actual label.
That result is our error value,
which we'll use grading dissent to
optimize automatically by computing a
gradient.
Of course this gradient is a signal
that tells our network how much do you
update it's wade values to make it better.
Once trained we can visualize how well
our network predicted at the price went
up or down on a given day.
And luckily for us it's a
better than 50% prediction.
Obviously with more data our network
will be more robust and while overfitting
is a common problem in price prediction,
we can use techniques like drop out
and regularization to prevent this from
happening in future versions.
So what should you remember?
Crypto currency prices are
highly driven by speculation,
and we can use sentiment analysis from
social media to help predict future
prices. Sentiment analysis is the process
of using machine learning algorithms to
analyze the emotions behind data from
people and LSTM networks proved to be a
useful model to help
analyze sequential data.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to predict the future,
so thanks for watching.